محافظه العلا بالسعوديه وتحديدا منطقه
الحجر المدرجه على قوائم يونسكو للتراث
العالمي هي الان في ميتافيرس الموقع كما
ينشاؤه رقميا عبر الانترنت من خلال منصه
ديسترا لاند ويقدم تجربه دخول المقابر
القديمه بالموقع واستكشاف المكان عبر
افاتار او نسختك الافتراضيه والتي لا يمكن
الوصول اليها في العالم الحقيقي لاسباب
تتعلق بحمايه الموقع تامل الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلا ان زياره النسخه الرقميه
للموقع ستشجع الناس على القيام بالرحله في
الواقع
نادين انت زرت العلا ومنطقه الحجر مستعده
تزوريها مره ثانيه بالميتافيرس يعني انا
لا مستعده ازورها كمان مره ثانيه انا
دائما عم بشجع الناس على زياره لانه قاعده
عم بفكر بقول انه قديه انت بجوا العلب على
الواقع الحياتي مش واقع افتراضي بتحسي انك
قاعده هيك في مكان خيالي
قاعده بالواقع الافتراضي